bitcoin is one of the best performing
assets over the last decade and now
there are more institutional products
that are starting to show up around the
world various asset managers have rushed
to the public markets to try to help
institutions foundations endowments
pension funds and others get access to
digital sound money now of course as
these various vehicles come to market
regulators who oversee the public
markets they want to have a say over
what actually gets approved and what
doesn't in the united states we already
have a bitcoin futures etf and now today
will be the first day where a bitcoin
short futures etf begins to trade now
this bitcoin short futures etf comes
from proshares one of the companies that
also has the bitcoin futures etf and
what's so interesting about this if you
ask the ceo of proshares is he said as
recent times have shown bitcoin can drop
in value biti affords investors who
believe that the price of bitcoin will
drop with an opportunity to potentially
profit or to hedge their cryptocurrency
holdings biti enables investors to
conveniently obtain short exposure to
bitcoin through buying an etf in a
traditional brokerage account now of
course there are a lot of folks who will
say if you're allowed to go long bitcoin
in an institutional manner in the public
market of course it makes sense to also
approve and allow investors to go short
that same asset but as will clemente
pointed out in the united states today
we've got a short bitcoin etf a futures
etf a closed end fund trading at a 30
plus discount a 401k option for bitcoin
but still there is no spot bitcoin etf
now will claims that gary ginzal and the
sec have an agenda against bitcoin i
don't necessarily agree that they have
some sort of agenda but i do think that
it's very rational to ask the question
if we're going to allow all these other
vehicles like the futures etf the short
etf gbtc 401k options and many other
institutional oriented vehicles why do
we not have a bitcoin spot etf yet
that's a question the regulators are
going ahead they're debating they're
trying to figure out whether they will
approve it or not ultimately gbtc which
has thousands of different investors is
trading at a 35 discount in the moment
and given its size that is a material
amount of money it's billions of dollars
that investors will recover if all of a
sudden they're allowed to convert gbtc
into a bitcoin spot etf and allow that
redemption functionality to enter into
the market and have the discount turn
back and be more even with nav
ultimately a bitcoin spot etf will get
approved in the united states in my
opinion i don't know when it's going to
happen and neither do most market
participants but i think that the chorus
is getting louder and people are saying
if all these other vehicles are allowed
why can't we have the bitcoin spot etf
hey you did you like this video great we
make five of them a day and post them
here on this channel make sure you
subscribe like the video and see you
next time